welcome back to cbs this morning about
27
000 people in southeast texas have been
told to boil your top water after the
death of a six-year-old little boy
josiah mcintyre of lake jackson south of
houston died nearly three weeks ago
from a rare but often fatal amoeba in
his brain
the organism was found in the local
water supply maria villareal
joins us now maria how did he get this
illness
good morning gail right now city
officials in lake jackson are telling us
they believe they either he either got
it from a local playground which has
since been closed down or the water hose
at his home
we spoke with his mom last night she was
extremely emotional obviously
after losing her son she says he started
complaining about headaches
and she had no idea what was causing
them at the time
he was extraordinary he was the happiest
most
active sweetest little soul
maria castillo lost her son josiah to an
infection she never saw coming
along with his headache and his fever
and his vomiting
he couldn't stand up properly he was
losing all
his faculties yes he was telling me that
he was dizzy
at the hospital doctors told josiah's
family that his brain was swelling
after several days of testing it turned
out to be nigleria fowleri
a rare but mostly fatal brain-eating
amoeba
he died just days later according to the
cdc
the organism is most often found in warm
freshwater lakes and rivers
in rare instances like in the case of
mcintyre humans can get infected when it
travels up the nose to the brain
where it destroys brain tissue but they
cannot get infected by
swallowing it now state officials are
scrambling to figure out how the amoeba
got into the water supply
we have a cross contamination somewhere
in our system or could it be
wells as well texas health officials
found three out of 11 samples taken from
the area were positive
for the deadly bacteria over the weekend
eight cities in southeast texas were
told to avoid using tap water
those restrictions have since been
lifted a boil water notice remains in
effect for lake jackson
leaving residents stocking up on bottled
water
unfortunately almost everyone who gets
it
ends up passing away dennis kyle is a
professor of infectious diseases at the
university of georgia
he says doctors rarely test for amoebas
early on often the problem is
they do not diagnosis until very late in
the infection
physicians are getting better about
thinking about warm fresh water exposure
and these sort of symptoms he says
there's very little known about brain
eating amoebas or how to treat them
he and a team of researchers are now
studying how repurposing current drugs
can be used to fight them early why
speak about this knowing that you guys
are going through a lot of pain right
now
i never thought something so rare would
happen to me or my family
six years into his little life and i had
to
let go of my baby the more people like i
said that are aware of it
if that's one life that can be safe from
that
than that that means a lot to me and
it means a lot to our families
city officials right now are rushing to
find the source of this amoeba so nobody
else gets infected experts say that
diseases
associated with this amoeba have a 97
percent
mortality rate and as far as we know
there are only four cases
in the u.s where somebody has contracted
this disease's illness
and have survived anthony maria thank
you
wow what a just a terrifying story and
so important that maria castillo came
forward to tell people about what the
risks are with this i really feel for
her
yeah you you just i mean very
magnanimous of her to do when you know
that she's in so much pain and i just
think as a parent
it's the worst thing not to know what's
happening to your child when you're sick
when they're sick
and not figure it out helpless to watch
them suffer and not not be able to help
just heartbreaking what she went through
with her son